today on the matt wall show pbs has
teamed up with the new york city
department of education to bring
drag queens and children together we'll
discuss the never-ending efforts to
groom and sexualize children today
and five headlines including a democrat
congressman righteously screaming at
republicans for not
living in reality but what the hell do
democrats know about reality
and joe rogan gets into trouble for
daring to suggest that there might be
some
anti-white sentiment out there possibly
plus china institutes a new divorce law
that's
way better than our divorce laws we
could learn something at least with that
uh when it comes to uh to divorce and in
our daily cancellation i will respond to
the
to a popular youtuber who tried to
demolish and destroy
me for my views on masking all of that
and more today on the matt walsh show
[Music]
so i wonder sometimes just how brazen it
has to be just how in your face how
obvious how outrageous
before everyone fully understands that
there is a very real plot
to groom and sexualize our children this
is not something happening out on the
fringes it's not relegated only to
weirdos and sex offenders driving their
creepy vans around town
though many of the people doing it may
be sex offenders whether convicted or
not
i'm not sure how many of them drive vans
however the point is that the cultural
powers that be are preying on children
and doing it
out in the open often with little
resistance from the public
far from resistance oftentimes they're
applauded sometimes they do it with the
help of tax funding
and that brings us to a report from mary
margaret olahan
in the daily caller she writes quote a
children's show on pbs
featured drag queen and author uh
little miss hotmess singing dancing and
reading a book about drag queens to an
intended audience of three to
eight-year-olds
the episode is part of the series let's
learn a public television series
produced in partnership with pbs member
station
wnet and the new york city department of
education
um this according to the spokeswoman
lindy horvitz
she's the spokeswoman for wnet the
spokeswoman emphasized repeatedly that
let's learn
is not a pbs series but was made
available to pbs stations
the little hot mess episode first aired
march 31st she said and wnet
has received only a small handful of
messages complaining about the show
a tag on the pbs website says let's
learn helps children
ages three to eight with at-home
learning one-hour programs
feature instruction by educators and
virtual field trips
so i don't know if the drag queen thing
is an educator or if that's a virtual
field trip
i don't know there it is
um they only got a small handful of
messages complaining
as long as only a few people are
complaining then surely there's nothing
wrong
or perhaps we can use our own judgment
to determine whether this
is appropriate for children here's a
clip if you can stomach it
we are going to sing and dance it out
so get your singing voices ready
hmm now we're going to start with our
hips
the hips on the dry clean goes swish
swish swish
swish swish swish swish swish swish
the hips on the drag queen go swish
swish swish
all through the town
the hair on the dragon goes up up
up up up up up
up up the hair on the dragon goes
up up up all through
the town the shoes on the drag queen go
stomp stomp stomp
stomp stomp stomp me hear it stomp stomp
stomp
the shoes on the dragon go stomp stomp
stomp
all through the town
so there it is i hope that guy
felt as stupid doing that as he looked
just a cross-dressing man singing about
his hips to a group of elementary
schoolers
and we haven't gotten to the best part
yet that comes at the very end let's
watch that
the dance of the dragon goes
twirl twirl twirl twirl twirl
twirl twirl twirl twirl
the dance of the dragon goes
twirl two world world
[Music]
all through the town
big finish excellent
give yourselves a round of applause
i think we might have some drag queens
and training on our hands
so drag queens in training he's again
talking about three-year-olds
as i always like to emphasize anytime
this subject comes up and unfortunately
the subject of drag shows for children
comes up
quite a bit but as i like to emphasize
drag
is burlesque for gay men that's what it
is so if if
if your mind and soul are so numb at
this point that you don't
viscerally and immediately understand
why this is outrageously inappropriate
and grotesque
just imagine a scenario where a female
burlesque performer
from las vegas was brought in in full
costume to talk to young children and
encourage the four-year-old girls in
attendance
to become burlesque dancers i bet we
have some burlesque dancers in training
here
imagine that though i've been making
this point this comparison
for a while and i must admit that it may
be losing its punch a little bit
as we may indeed be reaching a point
where people
were a few people would object to a
burlesque dancer recruiting
four-year-old girls
it's hard to find a shared frame of
reference when making moral arguments
these days as we are surrounded by
amoral lunatics
and perverts sadly but in any case the
point remains
that drag is an inherently sexual
fetishistic
thing often the drag queens have names
that make that fact explicitly clear
never mind by the way we're not even
covering the fact of how degrading all
of this is to women which is one of the
first things that comes to mind every
time i see something like that
drag is a gendered form of blackface it
is a gratuitous parody of womanhood
a caricature it makes a cartoon of
femininity
that's what it's designed to do it
appropriates and demeans
and degrades and i would say that no
matter the ages of the spectators but
when you consider the ages here
the whole thing takes on an even more
sinister light now um
i can make this argument and i have many
times but what i wish i could
really do is toss the ball back into the
other
side of the court i would like for those
who are okay with this
or in favor of it actively in favor of
it
to explain why because they never really
do if you notice
reading stories to children is great i'm
all for that singing
songs to children is great i'm not gonna
be the one to sing them but
that's good too but why do you want a
man in a female costume to do it
of all the candidates to sit and read a
story
why that it's not like there's a
shortage of people who can read stories
to kids
and so we're forced to hire drag queens
to do the job that americans won't do
that's not the case
no this is done for a reason what is
that reason
the most we'll ever be told is that we
need the drag queens to promote
tolerance and uh inclusivity but again
why do you need drag queens specifically
for that purpose
why are they the ones carrying the
tolerance torch
for children well
perhaps the word tolerance here is
actually quite apt
the tolerance that the left is after is
it is tolerance but its tolerance in the
same way that we might talk about
pain tolerance or tolerance of alcohol
another term might be conditioning or
desensitization
the idea is to expose the kids to all
forms of debauchery and weirdness early
on
so that they're numb to it and less able
to resist it less interested in
resisting it as they grow older
now just to amplify the point consider
for a moment the uh the cinderella
remake which is currently in the works
by sony pictures the new film will
feature of course a quote diverse cast
including a quote genderless fairy
godmother called
fab g played by actor billy porter
let's listen to billy porter because
this is kind of instructive
here he is in an interview a little
while ago explaining
his role and why he thinks that it's so
profound
let's listen what hit me when i was on
the set
last week how profound it is
that i am playing the fairy godmother
they call it the fab g magic has no
gender
um we are presenting this character as
genderless at least that that's how i'm
playing it
and it's really powerful you know this
is
a classic this is a classic fairy tale
um for a new generation and i think
that the new generation is really ready
you know the kids are ready it's the
grown-ups that are slowing stuff down
that is true that quote put that quote
on a t-shirt
put that quote everywhere yeah like kids
are okay with it uh
a couple questions immediately come to
mind like why is the dude wearing
my grandmother's fake house plants on
his head
and why does he look like he's smelling
a fart after every sentence that he
utters but
anyway oh the quote at the end there
you hear the it goes back to the anchors
they say oh yeah put put that quote on a
t-shirt put it everywhere
well what quote are they talking about
the kids are ready
to be clear that's the quote that the
two weirdos at the end are referring to
that's the quote that got them all
excited the kids are ready
or as the guy on the left paraphrased it
the kids are okay with it
he actually said that i don't know about
you but to me
the kids are okay with it and the kids
are ready sounds less like a rallying
cry for the masses and more like the
rationalizations of a predator
and that's not far off the mark in fact
i mean that's what it is after all what
do these people
think that the kids are ready for
exactly what do you mean they're ready
ready for what according to the left the
kids are ready to adopt all of their
most
radical sexual dogmas and
they're ready quote unquote because
adults have conditioned them for it
quite intentionally but in truth of
course
kids are not ready for any of this
they're not ready for
drag queens they're not ready for gay
gender bending fairy godmothers they're
not ready to have
the left's gender identity madness
voiced upon them
they're not quote unquote ready because
they're children
and they should be allowed to remain
children to remain innocent
to remain in a stable
comprehensible understandable reality
where boys are boys and girls or girls
that's what they're ready for that's
what they need
but our degenerate culture has has
always
other ideas let's get now to our five
headlines
[Music]
you know sometimes it can feel like we
are surrounded out there
in the culture and all of the
institutions especially all the
corporations and companies
are against us and many of them are you
know uh
that's the truth but not all and when we
find a company that's on our side it's
so important to support them
companies like charity mobile the
pro-life phone company five percent of
your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice
and um there are a lot of great perks
that come with it as well because it's a
wonderful service new activations and
eligible accounts get a free cell phone
with free activation
and free shipping there's no contracts
there's no termination fees there's no
risk with a 30-day guarantee
so if you're thinking that you might
want to change cell phone companies then
give charity mobile a try
and you're going to love you're also
going to love the fact they have live
customer service based right here in the
usa
free usage alerts free apps to monitor
your credit and all the while you're
helping to build a culture of life in
america
supporting a pro-life phone company you
can turn everyday living
into effortless giving for the charity
of your choice and it really becomes the
ultimate
win-win for you so call charity mobile
at 1-877-474-3662 or chat with them
online at charitymobile.com
new lower monthly plan prices and a new
plan with a higher data limit existing
customers automatically get the new
lower plan prices no need to contact us
and ask for them
so again charitymobile.com all right um
and i should let you know by the way
that uh you will be unfortunately
deprived of my presence tomorrow i'm not
gonna be here taking one day off
and i am um going
i i'm going on a quick trip for a few
days
and i'll be driving it's 11 hours i'm
driving
rather than rather than take a plane
that's how i've always been someone i'm
going to
i'm going to err on the side of driving
as much as i could get away with it
to avoid a plane but at this point
especially now
with all of the regulations they still
have in place you got to wear a mask the
whole time they just made it absolutely
miserable it was already
miserable flying i already hated it and
over the last year they've
they've done everything they can to make
it even more uncomfortable and degrading
into humanizing
um and it's i will yeah i will drive
11 or 12 hours easily rather than get on
a plane
even if that trip would have been an
hour and a half
um i i'm quickly reaching a point
especially if they don't lay off this
masking stuff
which on planes who knows if they ever
will
but i'm quickly reaching up reaching a
point where it's going to be like if if
i
if i can't reach you by car then i'm
just never gonna ever see you again
because i'm not getting on a plane uh
all right let's
start here house republicans yesterday
opposed a measure to form a commission
to investigate the events of january 6th
they want to have a january 6 commission
to investigate because because
we haven't investigated enough there
aren't enough investigations already
there are as far as i can tell like
dozens of investigations
into this um into you know people
trespassing in capitol hill
federal local dc's all
all levels of government various
agencies
they're tracking these people down and
anyone they can find
any little old grandmother who you know
cross
the uh cross the threshold into the
building for 15 seconds
they're gonna they're gonna they're
sending swat teams to our house to put
her in prison for for 17 years
but it's not enough we need more more
investigations
as far as investigating the uh rioting
that happened
and terrorized our cities for months on
end and in which
uh dozens of people were killed and
billions of dollars was was
damaged was inflicted no they're not we
don't need to investigate that
so obviously uh this should be opposed
republicans should oppose it and not
every republican did i think 30
plus were were on board with the with
the
commission um it should be a post for
that reason
because again of the double standard but
also because
you absolutely know that this is going
to become a political which it's already
a political
witch hunt but a january 6th commission
that's all it's going to be
transparently it's going to be a
political witch-hunt
so uh republicans opposed it and that
that led to a lot of
stunned reactions by democrats who were
to take it aback offended
stunned how how could you not be we were
we were under siege we were attacked
our lives were in jeopardy you don't
want to investigate this
more how dare you that was generally the
reaction summarizing
uh but representative tim ryan democrat
obviously from i think ohio
he uh they were all competing to
get on cable news and to have the most
self-righteous kind of
reaction but i think tim ryan managed to
take the cake let's let's uh watch
his performance gentlemen uh is
recognized for 30 seconds
i want to thank the gentleman from new
york and the other republicans who are
supporting this and thank them for their
bipartisanship to the other 90 percent
of our friends on the other side of the
aisle
holy cow incoherence
no idea what you're talking about ben
gods that you guys
chased the former secretary of state all
over the country
spent millions of dollars we have people
scaling the capital
hitting the capitol police with lead
pipes across the head
and we can't get bipartisanship what
else has to happen
in this country cops this is a slap in
the face to every rank and file cop
in the united states if we're going to
take on china
if we're going to rebuild the country if
we're going to reverse climate change
we need two political parties in this
country that are both living in reality
and you ain't one of them i yield back
the balance back
well who then who what what which
political party is living in reality
tim your political party is living in
reality
oh yeah uh one quick question can a man
get pregnant
i wish someone had had stood up and
asked like hey tim
uh you're living in reality over there
uh can you get pregnant
curious
just see what he says because they could
have asked him that hey tim can you
personally as a man are you able to get
pregnant
he would not be able to say no he
wouldn't be able to say no to that
i don't have to say say something like
uh oh no i haven't tried
possible and that's that's living in
reality to him
i i have no interest in defending
republicans
you know they don't they have no
interest in defending themselves
so i'm not going to get up here all
angrily defending my side i don't even
consider republicans to be on my side
they're not on my side
um so it's not he can scream at
republicans all i want
all he wants i don't care
but the the idea the notion that
democrats are living in reality
and the great irony that he says that
right after
saying we need to reverse if we want to
reverse climate change
we need to live in reality uh what
you know tim because what is going to
prevent us from reversing climate change
is that we live in reality
and in reality you can't flip a switch
and control the weather
you can't reverse the climate you can't
you can't
come up with a government policy that's
going to change the weather you
maniac
uh oh that's that's reality too reality
two is that there's a policy that a
government could put in place
to change the weather to make hurricanes
go away
my god and uh and
it's delusion on top of delusion because
right before that
he's pretending to care about cops this
is an insult
to all of the rank and file police
officers
that i just decided to start caring
about
a couple of months ago but only in this
one instance
the democrat it is
really hard to watch
democrats pretend to care about cops
you want to talk about not living in
reality
yeah they they have found there is there
is
one there's just one okay
and test test me on this because find me
an example of another one but
as far as i can tell there is one dead
cop
there's only ever been one that these
scumbags have cared about and that was
officer from brian signick
and they cared about him because they
thought his death was useful to them and
then they stopped caring when they
discovered that oh
actually he died of natural causes and
wasn't killed by the rioters at all
so they for the the sliver of time when
they thought that
either they thought that the the writers
killed cynic or they thought they could
get away with pretending the writers
that killed him
um that's when they cared
that's it there's a brief moment of time
when they cared about a dead cop
because there are thousands of other
dead cops that they've never said a word
about and don't give a damn about
and meanwhile tim ryan and all the rest
of them
they're out there telling people
that uh that that cops are trying to
track them down and kill them you know
this fantasy of of uh racist
cops hunting black men and murdering
them in the street
you think maybe that's an insult to the
rank and file how do you think the rank
of file feels about that
how do you think the rank of five police
officers feel every time one of them
is in a life or death struggle with an
assailant with a with a with a with a
criminal dirt bag
and has to use lethal force because
they've been given no choice and they
know
that you are going to throw them
directly under the bus accuse them of
being a
racist murderer and do everything in
your power to destroy their lives and
destroy their families lives how do you
think the rank of file feel about that
i know how they feel because i hear from
them all the time off the record
and sometimes on the record
these people man completely shameless
and it's it's the scary thing is that
it's
almost convincing you you watch that and
if you had no frame of reference at all
and you watched that little uh spiel
from from tim ryan
you would almost think that he that he
really believes that he actually gives a
damn about cops
that he cares about reality
that he's really if he just wants
justice and he's offended that other
people aren't
on board with it you might believe it
if you didn't know any better
he's not a bad actor
but the fact that they're such
convincing liars is what is uh so scary
not all of them are but but some of them
are
all right number two joe rogan got in
trouble this week uh for
some offensive comments that he made on
his podcast and i'll play the clip this
is a clip it
went viral people were upset about it
and uh
it's kind of a where's waldo type of
thing can you spot the offensive moment
in what he says here
it's not it's not it's not as easy as
you might think let's listen
you can never be woke enough that's the
problem it keeps going it keeps going
further and further and further down the
line and if you get
to the point where you capitulate where
you
agree to all these demands it will
eventually get to
straight white men are not allowed to
talk right because it's your privilege
to express yourself when
other people of color have been silenced
throughout history it will be
you're not allowed to go outside because
so many people were imprisoned for so
many years i mean i'm not joking no i
know i know it really will get there
it's that crazy you know we just got to
be nice to each other man
and there's a lot of people that are
taking advantage
of this weirdness in our culture and
then that becomes
their thing their thing is calling
people out for their privilege calling
people out for their position
you know so crazy times
it's so easy it almost takes the fun out
of it
in a way it's so easy to be
controversial
it's so easy to upset people to be
provocative
you don't even have to try i wish you
did have to try
i'm accused of being a provocateur
contrarian i'm just trying to upset
people
i wouldn't put it past me to do that
okay
um because i do enjoy it when a bunch of
morons are upset i
i do enjoy that i do enjoy that
spectacle and when they're all screaming
at me i think it's hilarious
but um but i don't know i don't have to
try to provoke
i'm really because i can simply
express really common sense viewpoints
that i of course totally believe and
get that kind of reaction so that's what
you just heard there from joe rogan
joe rogan provocateur
nothing about that was was surprising or
even arguable
yeah there's an anti-white male
sentiment out there of course there is
it's impossible to not notice it it's
everywhere
in fact if i were to take issue with
anything joe rogan said
it's the part where he said we're
getting to the point where
if you're a white male you're not
supposed to talk in fact in many corners
of society
and according to a lot of people we're
already at that point
there are a lot of people who think that
joe rogan should stop talking because
he's a he's a white male
and is privileged and doesn't understand
the lived experience of oppressed people
or whatever nonsense
so we are already at that point
for a lot of for a lot of people who
think that uh if you're a white male you
should just stop talking
all you have to do is listen to them and
they'll tell you they've told me
i hear that all the time that is one of
the most common rebuttals
to my completely common sense
non-surprising
ideas and positions one of the most
common rebuttals is you're well you're a
white male
which isn't a rebuttal at all obviously
but it's simply to to
to point out my sex and race is supposed
to be enough to shut down the argument
so yes we are at that point another
thing that's common sense and obvious is
that we're at the point of
an imminent alien invasion yes we're
back to the aliens again
number three is from the daily wire it
says a forthcoming report on the defense
department's advanced aerospace threat
identification program and its
investigations into unidentified aerial
phenomenon is expected to be
quote difficult to explain according to
officials close to the matter and it
will contain
information about ufo sightings all over
the world not just those reported by the
american military
um the report is expected shortly as the
end of the 180-day countdown which began
when president donald trump signed a 2.3
million credit virus relief bill into
law in december
is nearing cnn reported at the time that
a stipulation that the director of
national intelligence and the
secretary of defense had six months to
produce information about the threat
identification program was tucked into
the committee comment section of the
intelligence authorization act
for fiscal year 2021. um
so this is one of those things where you
you kind of sneak
an unrelated item into a bill that has
nothing to do with it because really
probably the ufos have nothing to do
with coronavirus relief unless the
aliens are coming
and are going to help us out with that
maybe they have a cure for all diseases
possible but um it seems like it was
snuck in
even though it's unrelated normally i'm
opposed to that
but if it involves ufos i will make an
exception
um pentagon sources told the daily wire
the report will likely be released
june 1st i'm i am so excited for this
this to me this is like probably how
most
people feel when there's a new star wars
movie or
marvel movie coming out i feel no
excitement about that at all
but this to me this to me is that that's
how excited i am
for this i know i'm getting my my and
and much like the star wars or marvel
movie you hope
your hope's way too high and it's a
disappointment that's probably going to
happen here as well
the only only additional thing i'll say
about the alien issue okay
for all of those i only want you to take
this into consideration
for all of those who have confidently
declared that um
there's no way this is this is space
aliens that can't be it it's got to be
it's got to be this or that explanation
now i agree as much as i hate to admit
it
and i've said all along that the reason
why i think the ufos are from aliens
eighty-five percent of my reason is
emotional i want it to be true
and so i am being swayed by that i fully
admit that that's the case
um but even so
it and so if i would put the emotions to
the side i have to admit that
that on the list of possible
explanations
um probably space aliens it's not at the
top
but it's on the list like it's in the
top ten at least
of possible explanations and that's
exciting
but for those who who have ruled it down
there are a lot of people that i've
talked to who seem to have including
people
i must say here at the daily wire who
have ruled out that explanation like
it's not even possible that can't be it
well how can you do that
given because in order to
come up with some idea of the
probability that these are aliens
you need to know about some of the
background probabilities
so for example we would need to know in
order to assess the probability
that this the ufos are familiar with any
degree of accuracy
we would need to know whether there are
other intelligence
beings in the universe where they are
how many of them are out there how many
civilizations
um and what technology they have
so you you would need all of that
information in order to accurately
assess the probability that any
particular unidentified object is from a
space alien
but we don't know any of that we have
zero clue we have no idea
so if there are intelligent
civilizations
all over the universe including right
next door if our surrounding solar
systems
that are still 20 plus trillion miles
away but
in galactic terms or right next door if
those if our surrounding solar systems
are full of intelligent life which is
possible
then that would make the alien
explanation for the ufos much more
plausible
but if we're alone in our galaxy
certainly for alone in the universe then
that means it's impossible those are
aliens
if we're alone in the galaxy even um if
there's just one intelligent
civilization per galaxy that would still
make 100 billion intelligent
civilizations but
that would make the possibility of of
the you know that would make the the
probability of the alien explanation
much lower
um but that's the point we don't know
any of that we have no idea
which means that of course i can't sit
here and say oh they're definitely
aliens but i'm not saying that nobody is
saying that
those of us who are open to it we're
only saying maybe it could be
there's something going on here that's
right now unexplainable
somebody has technology that's hundreds
of years beyond what we think is what we
currently think is possible
like we know all of that and it's just a
matter of who
so the open-minded and i'm not normally
in the open-minded camp for most things
but in this case i am the open-minded
among us are saying it's possible
it's the alien explanation for those who
are saying it's not possible i guess
what i'm asking is
you have this information about the
universe why aren't you sharing it you
could have a nobel prize by now
you you have determined somehow that
they're that we're alone in the universe
you've proven this
well give your findings to the nobel
committee
what are you what are you doing just
sitting around with it
oh you don't know you have no clue at
all you have absolutely no
idea what is out there in the universe
none
and yet you're confident that you could
say oh yeah
i mean i look up at the sky i don't see
any aliens up there so they can't be
there
come on it's absurd speaking of absurd
um i've had this on the docket for a few
days i'm going to finally get to it
this is from barons.com pablo picasso's
femme pre de un fenatre
i know i nailed that pronunciation
achieved uh 103 million dollars
at christie's live stream 20th century
auction in new york
thursday night marking the first time a
painting has sold at auction for more
than 100 million dollars in nearly two
years
the price place is uh fem among
picasso's top 10 works at auction
according to giovanni giovanni
bertazzoni
christie's vice chairman of 20th and
21st century art it was the highlight in
the evening of huge sales that realized
a total
price of 415 million dollars this is
what the rich people
are spending their money on and i have
to agree maybe i have to agree with the
socialists on that maybe the socialists
do have a point
the rich people are out of control
because you look at this painting sold
for 100 million 103 million dollars
don't mean to undersell it here
that 100 million dollars for that
my my four-year-old has drawn
almost something that looks exactly like
that if i could do it
forget about my four-year-old if i can
draw it
it's not great art there's not even the
correct number of fingers on the lady
look at that she's only got four fingers
and then her other hand has no fingers
just like what is she wearing a mitten
and she's got some massive growth on her
head
someone told me i was that okay that
painting there's garbage that's trash
that's not real art that's bad the rich
people are out of control
spend a hundred million dollars on that
you might as well you might as well do
be like the joker in dark knight and and
put all the money in a big pile
on the ground and burn it you know that
would be performance art
more meaningful than this trash painting
every we all know right everyone knows
that picasso
these picasso paintings are garbage and
we all know that and but some of you are
pretending otherwise because you want to
seem sophisticated
someone told me i was complaining about
this and on twitter and someone said
that
uh well you don't know anything about
art that's uh that's great cubism
that's the cubism technique
i admit i don't know what cubism is
but i assume that cubism is another word
for
making garbage paintings i
don't care what the techn it may it may
have this may be a perfect
masterful application of that technique
so what
anyone can invent a technique and then
there and then come up with a painting
that's a perfect representation of
so what does that mean who cares
here's a technique that i i think i
invented i have a new tech i haven't
named it yet but it's a very artistic
technique
where i just um you know drink some
water
and then spit it out on a canvas i
didn't quite invent that there's
there are similar ideas jackson pollock
but uh
and i can make a painting and i say you
know this is the the the
you know the regurgitation technique
i'll call it
i'll make a painting and say this is a
perfect example of the regurgitation
technique
now pay me 500 million dollars for it
uh am i jealous yes am i jealous that uh
i didn't think to do this and make 100
million absolutely i'm envious
all right let's move on now to
reading the youtube comments as i scroll
ahead to see if i have any i do
um major tom fisher says in defense of
they
as a singular pronoun i prefer using it
over he
she if i'm talking about someone who's
gender i don't know over the internet
i also sometimes prefer to use it for
transgenders instead of lying to the
person that they're really the gender
they claim to be
although using their name may be a more
effective tactic here
yeah i think my my strategy with
pronouns as i've said all along
is uh i'm gonna use the grammatically
linguistically correct pronoun in any
given situation if i know what it is
um but that's why i stipulated yesterday
the thing with they
is normally it's for plural when you're
talking about more than one person
but it can also be validly used when you
don't
when you're talking about an unknown
person sort of an unknown quantity
um you don't know who they are you don't
know their name you don't know their
their sex
um and you could use they in that case
so sure
and yeah i do prefer that over he she i
think he she is
ridiculous but you could also use he now
this has fallen out of fashion because
it's considered
patriarchal or something but
traditionally in the english language
if you don't if you're talking kind of
generally about people
or you're giving an example of a person
sort of a hypothetical person
you just go with he you don't need to
say he or she or even they
but yeah they is fine in that case um
but if you know
who the person is and you know whether
they're male or female
then no i would not use that it doesn't
make any sense in that context
um joshua says i think this
transgenderism issue is crazy but if a
grown man wants to be called a woman
that doesn't affect my life so i don't
see why we should care conservative is
going to lose
lose if we keep focusing on these
pointless issues that people in the
mainstream public don't really care
about
okay josh what what what issues do you
think what what issues do you think
people care about what should we focus
on instead
i'd like are you gonna tell me taxes or
something like that
tax policy
is that what is that what uh moves the
hearts of men
tax policy
yeah it's all a distraction reality is a
defending reality and science
and the english language that's a
distraction to you
and you'd rather move on from reality
who cares about reality what do we need
reality for
what has reality ever done for me
you know let's look at the tax rates can
we get those down a few a few
a smidge or two that's the battle that's
what that's what's going to get people
motivated
come on josh how can you even come here
josh with that weak sauce
you're coming to me with that go
somewhere else with that
haven't you heard me shouting about that
exact
line of thinking a million times
um you know what i almost banned you
from the show but i'm not going to
because i think you need to be
more exposed to what we're doing here
um evan says if you're gay you like
people of the same sex if you're
bisexual you like people of both sexes
even if you're transsexual it's pretty
well defined
queer pansexual and nine but non-binary
are ill-defined terms that you can slap
on yourself without needing to actually
explain what the hell they mean and
that's
exactly right that's that's the whole
point of it um
let's see hi matt i'm against capital
punishment and i'm also against putting
murderers in protective custody let them
out in the prison population whatever
happens happens
yeah i can understand that argument and
we were talking about yesterday the
horrific case of the uh 18 year old
guy who goes into a four-year-old's room
kidnaps him brings him outside and
murders him and leaves him on a bloody
puddle on the sidewalk dead um
that's why i said something like that i
i i would hope
you know you hear cases of
someone being in the general population
the prison guards
if they get distracted for a second you
know the shoe's untied they're gonna
they gotta bend down and tie it they're
just not paying attention
and when they're looking the other way
anything could happen
you hear cases like that
maybe that case will happen here it
wouldn't upset me any
but um as a as a policy you can't do
that
and the reason why you can't do it is it
just it's it creates
an unsafe chaotic environment in the
entire prison for the prison guards too
so i mean in reality as much as it
wouldn't bother me
um to just start feeding these people
into the piranha tank as it were
is going to create an unsafe environment
across the border for everybody
so you can't do that um which means that
really you don't have much of a choice
when you've got someone like this who's
killed a child
you're the kind of of a criminal who
commits a crime
so heinous that even other murderers
don't want to be around him you got
someone like that you for the sake of
the safety of the prison
and and maintaining some kind of
civilized order you have to segregate
them
and protect them basically and and so
now you're making this extra effort it
costs more money
um and the idea that we have to do that
for 60 plus years for a guy who goes in
at 18
rather than just removing him
permanently from society
and from the earth that to me doesn't
make a lot of sense
uh let's see finally
last comment says all daily wire
backstage shows should be done in a hot
tub
and the water from that show should be
bottled and sold after
you disgusting freak you want to buy our
used bath water
revolting gross you're banned from the
show
anyway how much would you pay for it
let's talk
you know it seemed like everything was
normal and then one day you look around
and everyone is sucking on these weird
pens with
steam coming out um and that's what
that's what the kids
call vaping these days we know that
vaping has
completely overwhelmed uh the the
country
and it's uh one of the most popular
things right now that's why wundery's
new podcast miniseries is really
interesting it's called the vaping fix
it's a story
of silicon valley idealism blind
ambition and how the now infamous
e-cigarette company jewel
hooked a new generation on vaping in
2015 the founders of jewel set out to
create
the ipod of e-cigarettes a perfectly
designed device that would
disrupt the tobacco industry and help
traditional smokers quit but their fruit
flavored vaping options high levels of
nicotine
and youthful influencer endorsements led
to consequences that would put millions
at risk as plumes of vape clouds
surround schools across the nation
parents politicians
and the government demand answers was
this jules plan all along or did
ambition blind them from seeing
the pitfalls of their invention hosted
by laura beale and uh from the team
behind dr death and bad batch comes
the vaping fix listen to the vaping fix
on amazon music apple podcast
or you can also listen early and ad free
by starting your free trial of wondery
plus in the wondery app yeah they say
sticks and stones may break my bones and
all that we know that words aren't
hurtful but the erasure of them is
i know this i talk about all the time
and michael knowles does too
enough to write a whole book about it
called speechless controlling words
controlling minds in it he breaks down
the history of political correctness and
what the future will resemble if it's
not stopped
so just head to speechlessbook.com to
pre-order your copy today or if you want
an extra personal touch
text speechless to 534
to pre-order a signed copy don't wait
pre-order your copy today and understand
the pc police
better than they even understand
themselves now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today the focus of our daily
cancellation is a guy named kyle
kalinski who's a youtuber
he has more subscribers than me on
youtube but then i have more followers
than him on twitter so the question of
which of us is a better person remains
therefore undecided guess we'll have to
compare facebook friends
anyway kyle uh dedicated a segment of
his show recently to addressing
me and an argument that i've made about
masking the title of the video with this
segment
is conservative weirdo really really mad
at mask wearers
i don't deny that um i'm probably a
weirdo but not because of my masking
stance that is without question the
least weird thing about me
kyle is specifically upset with me over
a recent tweet of mine on this issue i
believe i've already addressed this
tweet on the show but here it is for
your reference again
i wrote wearing a mask when not when it
is not medically necessary is grotesque
and on human an attack on society itself
it feeds paranoia and fear
you're treating air like it's toxic and
other humans like they're nothing but
vessels of disease it is disgraceful
arrogant and offensive
before we get to kyle's rebuttal let's
just once again consider the point that
i'm making
i stipulate that i'm referring to
medically unnecessary masks
masks i realize there are for example
people with serious illnesses or
compromised immune systems
who might wear a mask and would have
worn one before all of this
there are other scenarios too like let's
say you have severe allergies and you're
out cutting the grass i've always seen
some people wearing masks because of
that no problem
i'm not talking about any of those
categories or similar categories
what we're talking about is the
medically unnecessary masking so
as for that let's take it line by line
here
i call unnecessary masking grotesque and
unhuman
that's correct the only problem here
perhaps is the redundancy
it's grotesque because it is unhuman
humans acting in unhuman ways
are always grotesque and i would say
it's unhuman it's indeed an attack on in
the rejection of human society
when you walk around as if each person
who even passes by you on the sidewalk
might infect you with a disease and kill
you
to treat your fellow humans as
disease-carrying rodents
who are very likely to make you sick
even just by being in your general
vicinity for a few moments
is to my mind severely dysfunctional
behavior it is not mere caution
okay a man who washes his hands
periodically throughout the day
and after using the bathroom before
making food etc is cautious and
practicing good hygiene
we should all be cautious like that but
a man who scrubs at his hands for 45
minutes at a time
until they're bleeding is not cautious
he's sick
he's deeply disturbed and the masking
that i'm referring to
is worse in some ways than that because
the masker is projecting his pathologies
outward broadcasting them
wearing them on his face literally
i also say that it feeds paranoia and
fear i think that's pretty self-evident
it's the height of paranoia for a
physically healthy person who's not at
any significant risk of covid either
because of vaccination or prior
infection or whatever other reason
to to walk around as though they might
get infected if they if they allow
themselves to breathe fresh air for a
few moments paranoid yeah
absolutely that's paranoid and yes it
feeds paranoia in others
again it projects it outwards encourages
it spreads
spreads it much like the disease that
it's ostensibly supposed to be to be
protecting from
as for disgraceful arrogant and
offensive well yes
i would call it arrogant to treat your
fellow humans like they're nothing but a
threat to you
like they're sick diseased toxic plague
carrying
rats i would call that arrogant
absolutely
offensive i mean what does what does
offensive mean an act is offensive if
it's insulting rude
disrespectful and derogatory
i i do believe that the word offensive
is way overused i often complain about
its overuse
but i never said i never said that
nothing is offensive obviously some
things actually are offensive
the word means something and that
meaning applies
sometimes just because i object to its
overuse doesn't mean that i object to
its use
period and in this case yes i would say
it is offensive
to treat other people that way and to
treat society that way
okay so i have now reiterated my points
and explain them
i've argued my case i wanted to do that
ahead of time before we got to
kyle's rebuttal of the conservative
weirdo i.e yours truly
so i want to just ask for for you know
to set the stage that's all of that
explaining it
now let's listen to uh kyle now the
conservative now that uh the
government agencies decided
if you're vaccinated you don't really
need to wear it inside um conservatives
are aggressively coming out to
i guess do their version of an end zone
dance so there's this guy matt walsh
who's a conservative commentator and
here's what he says
wearing a mask when it is not medically
necessary
is grotesque and unhuman an attack on
society
itself it feeds paranoia and fear
you are treating air like it is toxic
and other humans like they are nothing
but vessels of disease
it is disgraceful arrogant and defensive
so now you have the anti-mass mask
brigade is becoming militant in their
anti-maskiness
that's what we're currently watching
look at the language he's using
so the government admits like okay
vaccinated people don't need to wear it
inside
and this is what this guy's reaction is
it is
wearing a mask is not medic wearing a
mask when it's not medically necessary
is grotesque
unhuman an attack on society itself it
feeds paranoia and fear
and you're treating air like it's toxic
and other humans like they are nothing
but vessels of disease
it is disgraceful arrogant and offensive
offensive these are the guys who call
other people snowflakes 24 7.
these are the guys who go after the libs
for being triggered
these are the guys who make fun of safe
spaces it sounds like this guy needs a
safe space for masks
so listen it's easy to dunk on this guy
and and have fun with it
it's easy to dunk then why haven't you
get around to it kyle you can start
dunking anytime if it's so easy at least
pull off a couple of windmills just to
show us what you got
i mean you're saying it's so easy to
dunk on this absurd position from a
weirdo and yet all you've done so far is
repeat my argument
in an incredulous voice that doesn't
count as an argument
raising your eyebrows and restating what
i said in a mocking tone
is not a rebuttal a parrot
could could literally do that a bird
could do that
just without the eyebrows i suppose
let's see if kyle gets around to
actually making an argument of some kind
at some point
so let's continue you shouldn't be
offend if somebody's outside
and they're not wearing a mask that's
fine they don't need to wear a mask
everybody relax
if somebody's outside and they are
wearing a mask they're being overly
cautious but
that's totally fine that's totally fine
if somebody's indoors and they're not
wearing a mask and they're vaccinated
that's fine if somebody's indoors
and they're wearing a mask and they're
unvaccinated or vaccinated
i think that's fine i think it's fine
i don't know why this became the
ultimate like culture war issue
but i just want to be clear that
everybody participating in it looks
colossally stupid
and honestly looking back at a tweet
like this in retrospect from the future
and this guy being considered an
intellectual on the right kind of
embarrassing for the right
i mean this guy saying stuff like this
it's like they're
proudly wearing their
anti-intellectualism
you know and
it's just sad i just sort of feel bad
for this guy
who's 100 percent caught in the culture
war and stuck
and he's like brainwashed by it to the
point where he says
deranged stuff like this
well thank you for your pity kyle i
don't need it though not for this anyway
a month from now i'll be going on a
vacation with four kids driving 16 hours
and i'll need your pity for that so
please store it up for that sort of
emergency
as for the tweet you're responding to i
feel great about it in fact we are in
the future right now and i'm looking
back on that and i couldn't be
happier that i said it especially
because nothing you have said in
response to it qualifies in any way
as an argument you seem very sure that
my argument is incomprehensibly stupid
and yet you're unable to actually
explain why
your entire rebuttal is yeah but i think
it's fine
i think it's fine it's fine
i'm glad you do but you say that i'm
anti-intellectual
and i never claimed to be an
intellectual in the first place i care
less
what label you put there um but to show
off your own intellectual prowess you
have eviscerated my position with
eloquent rhetorical flourishes like
he's a weirdo this is stupid and my
favorite
i mean this guy saying stuff like this
that was pr
that was my favorite counterpoint that
you raised i mean this guy come on
saying this stuff forget about it very
profound points kyle
i don't mean to pick on you but this is
a serious problem these days and
you just provide us with a handy example
of the problem people seem to think
that scoffing counts as an argument they
think that if they
encounter an idea that they consider
extreme all they have to do is smirk and
laugh and say
that's extreme and that'll be sufficient
to debunk
the idea it's not and it's especially
not in my case because i'm not
embarrassed to be labeled extreme
i don't care extreme just means i've
taken a position that's outside of
mainstream thought
and considering that mainstream thought
is so often shallow superficial
half-baked and misguided
i'm quite pleased whenever i find myself
outside of it
and the mainstream thought on masking
right now is that although masks have
existed for hundreds of years
and almost everyone went about their
lives without them and showed their
faces and breathed the air and
interacted with other neighbors
with other people and their neighbors
like normal humans now all of a sudden
there ought to be a tectonic shift where
it's considered normal or even advisable
to cover your mouth and nose
whenever you leave the house as if the
very air itself is radioactive
my point is that my extreme view
is actually just the mainstream view
of 15 months ago and every point before
that
the only difference is that i am not
floating with the tide of mainstream
opinion
i'm not going to radically recalibrate
my view of the world and of society
every time our culture tells me that i
should
if that's your approach so be it
but it's not mine and so for that reason
today
unfortunately i have to say that our
friend kyle
is canceled and we'll leave it there for
uh today and for the week i'll see you
back
here on monday have a great day great
week great weekend
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadosky the
show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
makeup is done by nikka geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021. democrats
change their tune on property
destruction and mostly peaceful protests
demi lovato identifies as multiple
people now
and a listener writes in to offer her
personal account of the dark side of
transgender ideology check it out on the
michael knoll show